actually they had a script for 10
episodes and that script during the
strikes was completely thrown out Sam
Ismael was asked by the studios to
completely start again and he's done so
they've pretty much got a pilot script
ready and that's ready to go um but the
rest of the season is now really up for
debate they have completely restarted
and reimagined the series and that
actually leads into my next point where
initially Sam asmail was talking about
that this show would actually exist
within universe of the original Battle
Star Galactica now he was always a
little bit vague on what that meant
because it's not necessarily going to be
a continuation it was going to be within
Universe though I told you um in a video
um just six or seven weeks ago actually
that there was a rumor this was going
back about 18 months that actually this
new series by samil would be a be a
little bit of a prequel that it was
going to be based and start around the
launch of the Battle Star